let's talk about this story oh the
story's crazy yeah so dumb family of
girls seemingly snubbed at sesame place
hire's lawyer considers a lawsuit
what so it's a slow news day and the
country's collapsing so how about this
story
rosita is that the name of the weird
stupid muppet rosita oh the green one
rosita was walking past two little black
girls who waved and reached out their
arms and rosita waved no
and then everyone erupted on twitter
like ben crump didn't he tweet like
you're racist or something so yeah
everybody was tweeting about it part of
me right now wants to just like turn
this off and go play spelunky or
something
we live in such a stupid stupid
time
it is entertaining
yeah i like it at first i was like that
seems kind of rude why didn't you do
that but then i was looking at what she
did before she did the same thing to
someone else she was like she put her
let's play the video don't give her it
here's the thing does she not touch
children or something just give hugs
she's hiding so look they're like we
want hugs she's giving high fives late
yeah no no no no no
no no no no
so the woke oh crowd is now moving for
those little girls do you see your face
i mean she should have high fived or it
should have hurt her face she's like
they wanted a hug but they don't hug
children they don't have anybody yeah
because they'll get sued if they get if
they hug them though they can't slow
down they're like oh it's not a parade
yeah and then everyone would want to hug
and you can't stop yeah you can't stop
you know then you get diseases from
covet or whatever but
i feel bad like they just wanted a hug
it's kind of sad but they went went nuts
saying it was racist
this is so crazy man this is where we're
at right now
where's you know we need we need north
macdonald back yeah he's great i'm just
kidding we just need his commentary and
everything because he'd be like what
well do large green monsters have racial
bias towards young black girls i didn't
i don't know like what they do i don't
have a lot of familiarity with what is
rosita what is it no idea is it a bear
it's a puppet it's a puppet oh wait then
she said she hugged a little white girl
next to us
when i complained he looked at me like
i'm crazy
so is that it i wouldn't need to see
evidence yeah
pixar didn't yeah sesame play said the
performer wearing rosita costume
gestured no several times in the video
not at the children but rather in
response to multiple requests for
someone in the crowd who asked rosita to
hold their child for a photo which is
not permitted
that's not what it looks like
yeah go back she says uh no she shakes
her oh that's right she the head looks
down and the mouth is where the eyes are
right i think so i don't know he's
saying no to the kids they're lying
that's sad yeah i don't know maybe it's
sad but like you can't see on video
the the rosita hugging a white kid or
whatever but i don't know maybe that
happened i think that's on hunter
biden's laptop video
yeah we should get into it for sure i
have long suspected sesame street of
being overtly racist and this just
confirms what we've already known that
muppet monsters just plain don't like
brown people and that's that's wrong i
mean the whole premise of sesame street
from the beginning was multi-rich like
literally like from like when it was
started in like 72 or something was what
made it so groundbreaking is that like
in the b well first of all it took place
like in the bronx on a stoop right or
like in brooklyn and it was in an urban
area and everyone was multiracial from
like the very first episode remember
when they did the first homeless muppet
oh yeah and then everyone was like yo
oscar the grouch would be living in a
trash
yeah
i don't know man this is this is just
the the absurdity that we live in it's
like you see these videos that video to
portland where the the two people are
fighting outside of their cars and the
white woman's like you're mad about your
oppression you're not mad at me and he's
like what get out of my face you
colonize her
and i'm just like yeah
that's amazing i'm here for it
i'm watching them fight with each other
it's fun but it kind of feels like we've
been yuri besmanov you know what i mean
they've planted the seeds of discord and
now people of fractured psyches are
fighting with each other over their
nonsense yeah
well then you have to ask the question
would this have happened anyway is this
like a result of human nature i
personally think it's a result of having
too much free time too much money and
these are like blessings have been taken
to an extreme like now we have nothing
to do we're bored we have no way to feel
special other than being victims which
is like a terrible place for a society
to be in and uh we're just too lucky for
our own good we celebrate victimhood we
do yeah that's why they're they're
trying to sue this little green monster
that's so dumb and and they're clearly
just looking for victimhood they lack it
and they want it to be because of race
they have nothing else which is really
sad it is it is and i agree with you
this this comes as the result of not
having real
problems in your life it's a lot like
again climate change yeah right like you
these are the these are the causes of
privilege if the worst thing that
happens to you today to you is that you
think your child was snubbed by a fake
green monster then life's not too bad
life's great right well that's why
they're so angry because it is the worst
thing's ever happened yeah yeah that's
true future's going to be nuts you know
there's going to be like humans are
going to be big balls of fat and jelly
sitting in hover chairs they're going to
have you know food tubes or they can
snap their fingers and have literally
anything they're going to be literally
gargling ice cream with like vitamins in
it and then one day there's going to be
a small burp in the like just
the two burps and they'll start
screaming and freaking out because the
burp was the worst thing they ever
experienced i i have to say when they
were talking about dystopias i had no
idea that our dystopia was going to be
like wall-e that is the closest thing to
the way it's actually going to be that
i've ever seen we need something like
wally to bumble through our freaking
wheelchairs and throw us all over but
the people in wally were chill
yeah they were just floating around like
whatever that was way off yeah soft
people floating around in chairs would
be super angry about just the
stupidest nonsense ever they'd be like
they'd get their slushie or whatever
from the robot and they'd look at it and
it would be like a millimeter less than
they wanted to
then they'll start crying and say they
were attacked and it's violence i was
murdered i was murdered that's right
except all the food is really made from
bugs yeah and it's just got flavorings
it's got monsanto flavorings to taste
like steak or that tastes like chicken
or beef well that's what it's all just
made of insects that's where we're
headed yeah it is
so why don't you eat the bugs daniel you
have a farm right yeah
i know certain you know cultures do eat
them i i don't you know i don't want to
eat bugs i'm not saying why not are you
racist
i'm like that green monster yeah um
do you know that 80 of the world eats
bugs
yeah like i said a lot of clothes that's
true who eat bugs is that is that a real
they're not eating bugs because they
want to it's because they're poor
yeah like yeah wealthy people don't eat
bugs eat coffee right so many bugs they
eat them as novelty they ate the best
part of the yeah oh they do celebrities
are like i'll try to try a chocolate
covered cricket whoa is that what you
eat yeah they do it's it's something
novel but no but i think when it comes
to food and what you're doing and
highlighting with the dutch farmers and
what i do in the energy space
you know it's it's very much related and
and food insecurity is a growing problem
and holy crap we haven't even started to
eat this year's food because we're still
growing it so we don't even know what
prices are going to cost you know i get
asked about gas prices but we haven't
harvested this year's wheat yet and and
if there's any to harvest exactly if
there's any fuel to harvest what little
we do have i know that's going to be fun
huh so so the real food prices are are
bad now but the real kick is not going
to come until
october november wait wait until the
fertilizer shortages kick in yeah well
they already did
they already i think earlier i think it
will be
a continual crisis next year it's gonna
be your harvest because yeah russia's
not gonna stop like the russian ukraine
stuff is not gonna stop but you know i
gotta say i'm very frustrated with you
guys look no one cares about food and
gas
they care about racist muppets and
abortions
racist muppets getting abortions yeah
that's that's something no no racist
muppets
stopping abortions oh snap that's the
problem can racist muppet men's get
abortions racist racist male muppets get
abortions or elmo gets an abortion oh my
gosh
oh that's the new dog oh no it's elmo
oh sure why not
what is elmo what does it matter almost
dude right i think elmo is almost a boy
what
elmo is a boy's name isn't it saint elmo
she almost fired but men can give birth
now that's true that's true it's so
close-minded of course it's like tickle
me elmo abort me elmo the new
how far out do you think we are from
children's dolls that can be can get
abortions um two months
that's a tough barbie didn't they do
did they use like a doll that
menstruates or something pregnant male
barbie i believe pregnant male barber
believe not sure you guys can fact
protect me on that pregnant male barbie
disturbing i wouldn't be surprised i
mean yeah frumpy barbie i mean it's all
part of grooming kids right they gotta
to yeah someone just banned groomer what
pla wasn't it it wasn't it's that story
was fake news oh it was oh yeah what
actually happened was that a single
subreddit said hey stop doing this
and that was it well
an article and then pink news is like
claimed that it was
groomer was calling all gay people peter
something like no just you i guess just
you yeah
yeah they said that it's a
groomer is an anti-lgbtq slur and i'm
like no no no it isn't i thought that
just the groomers what the heck but like
the joke i made the other day or the
point was there's like a creepy guy
looking at kids looking at his lips and
then you're like you point to him and
you're like hey you you groomer you get
out of here and then he walks over next
to the gay guys and goes hey he's he's
making fun of us
and it's like no i'm not making fun of
them i'm telling you to get out of here
those guys are all right they're true
they're minding their own business i
don't care yeah
yeah pregnant ken is satire just for the
record i would put it at like six months
out i definitely see that happening it
does sound like a babylon b yeah it does
toy but the whole world sounds like a
babylon beer at this point to be fair
but you raised a great point though like
about about what we were talking about
energy issues food issues but we do love
to get distracted by
what's that benefit benefit got married
that was i woke up the other morning and
usually one of the first things i do
which is a terrible habit you look at
what happened while i was asleep pulled
up my phone
start
first five stories we're all about ben
affleck and jennifer lopez getting
married and you're like really something
else must have happened last night
thanks for checking out this clip from
tim cast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time